live chairman
thank you sarah good afternoon and
welcome to this joint standards
committee meeting on monday the 23rd of
february
to 2021. my name is councillor mark
bassinger and i'm the chairman of this
committee
this committee this meeting is held
under new regulations which came into
effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
kovit 19 pandemic
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
camera remains on where broadband
permits
and your microphone remains muted when
not addressing the committee
this will reduce background noise and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating a wish to raise
a point of order or that you are to
leave the meeting the chat function
should not be used for
for any other purposes
members when speaking and referring to
the agenda papers
please reference a page or paragraph
number and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn your microphones
on now if i may ask officers taking part
in the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr hodgson
good afternoon norman hudson i'm the
outgoing independent person
um i've got my p45 but i'm here again
today
don't think you expected to see me again
but i'm here
good afternoon mr austin nice to see you
actually uh mr crouch please
yeah simon quelch um i'm i'm the
council's monitoring officer and i'm
only remaining in the open session of
the meeting
when it goes into private and
confidential emma holmes will
will take over that role thank you son
miss holmes please
thank you chair i'm emma holmes i'm the
deputy monitoring officer
um and lead sorry senior legal
specialist
great thank you tara
good evening check out evening members
um my name is tara bird i'm committee
services officer for the meeting
um any other officers present please
okay it looks like there are none before
i call on the clerk to take the roll
call of committee members
can i ask those counsellors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
good afternoon councillor vanessa bell
in attendance apologies i'm having some
internet issues
so uh no camera i'm afraid good
afternoon vanessa
good morning councillor chrissy morris
lurking
good afternoon councillor morris glad
you're lurking
okay great is that
everybody
tara okay please can you now carry out a
roll call of members to confirm who is
in
attendance please thank you yes of
course chairman um members if you could
just indicate if you're here please
and starting uh with cancer boyce please
yeah thank you councillor mrs fleming
president thank you tara thank you
councillor hull
present here tara thank you councillor
maze
present tara good afternoon thank you
very much councillor stiltz
good afternoon tower i'm present and
then chairman we've got three substitute
members
councilman spiel president
good afternoon tara present thank you
and councillor seanacy
thank you tara present chairman that
concludes the role call
thank you very much tara um okay agenda
item number two apologies for absence
uh tara may i have the apologies for
absence please
oh yes thank you chairman um we've got
apologies
from uh councillor nunn councillor
siddal council mrs thompson
and then in accordance with notice julie
given a councillor heard
attending a substitute for councillor
nunn councillor shaughnessy as
substitute for councillor siddal
and councillor miss beale as a
substitute for councillor mrs thompson
thank you thank you very much okay we'll
move on to
uh agenda item three which are the
minutes
uh it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 26th of january
2021 found on pages 5 and 8
are approved as a true and accurate
record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion
please unmute your microphone and state
your name now
seconded councillor fleming
thank you very much to councillor
fleming
if any member wishes to raise a matter
of accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i'll invite you to speak
okay it doesn't like tara could you
advise if any members ask to speak
please
thank you chairman no we have no one
indicating to speak thank you
thank you uh tara we will now take the
vote or do we wish to agree those by
ascent
committee we can agree by assent
agreed agreed okay thank you very much
that's agreed then thank you tara
thank you chairman
item number four declarations of
interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interest
other bikini interests or non-binary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
and i can see tara that we have two
members so
could i go to our councillor maze please
uh yeah thank you mr chairman i'd like
to um disclose
a non-pecuniary um interest
in item number
seven uh on the basis that i attended as
an observer the northwest planning
meeting
um as i attend many other meetings thank
you
thank you very much uh could i now go to
councillor stilts please
thank you chairman i don't have the
minutes in front of me unfortunately
because i'm working on one screen
instead of two
uh it's a non-computing uh interest
um although the monitoring officer did
say that unless we
are very close to someone are you going
out with drinking etcetera
it doesn't count i just like to mention
i do know mr
um miss jarvis uh non-compunary
um met him when i was the mayor and
that's the only
and i i'm also of a a non-political
um association um
there's nothing to do with the council
uh i i'm aware of him
thank you thank you very much councilman
so as mayor just say before this kicks
off a sort of uh you know everyone
declaring non-binary interest
we do all know um both of the councils
in question i presume so we can sort of
take that as read i believe
we've sort of been through this all
before so unless you do have a special
relationship as as councilor stewart's
felt he did
um i think we can all leave that as is
uh so could i go to councillor boyce
please
thank you chairman on the advice of the
monitoring officer
um a personal interest
in that i've got a complaint against
councillor morris
so i will not speak or vote
on the council of morris agenda item
and in regards to councillor jarvis
he has given evidence
against me however i don't
i think that i may be able to speak
although i will not vote on that case
either thank you chairman
thank you councillor boyce uh is there
anybody else tara who wishes
to speak please
uh chairman councillor sean c has also
indicated she was speaking i
am terribly sorry councillor sean c um
no no that's fine chairman thank you um
just non-pecuniary um as in item seven
i have seen the um the video of the
planning
meeting thank you okay thank you very
much
i think tara can i move on
uh yes chairman i can see no other hands
up thank you
thank you very much so i shall now move
to
item five uh any other items of business
that the chairman of the committee
decides
are urgent members in accordance with
section
100b 4 of the local government action
1972 i have agreed to allow the lead
legal specialist and monitoring officer
to raise an urgent item of business
seeking a dispensation for councillor
stephen nunn
at the forthcoming extraordinary meeting
of the council
this matter is brought forward for
urgent consideration
as a decision is required before the
extraordinary council meeting on the
23rd of february 2021
i now call on the lead legal specialist
and monitoring officer
to present his urgent report members a
reminder that if you wish to speak
please make this known by using the
hands up function
and i will come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr quelch please would you present the
report
yes thank you very much chairman and and
naturally there is no
written report because this was only
raised a very short notice
when i became aware of certain
information so thank you chairman for
allowing it to be
brought in as an urgent item as a result
of that
counsellor nurn wrote to me
and asked about the possibility of a
dispensation i'd raised that issue with
him
um whether he wanted that and he said he
did
so we've had an email from him now um
let me just give a little bit of
background section 33 of the localism
act 2011 gives
power to the local authority to to grant
a dispensation
to a member or members
um when there might be a disclosable
pecuniary interest
or other pecuniary interest or
non-pecuniary interest to actually
debate and vote on a matter despite
their particular interest
and we have the budget meeting tomorrow
councillor nurn has a particular
interest in one
small aspect of one report
but because of the way that um
the way the reports should probably be
voted on where they should be voted on
collectively as one um one budget
it's more expeditious and certainly far
easier
if councillor none and any other member
in fact
um who has a disclosable pecuniary
pecuniaries that i don't know of at this
particular moment
can actually participate in the budget
um by actually declaring they have this
particular pecuny interest
but they're not prevented from voting
or debating the issue um now
chairman i i did give a suggestion of a
proposal
which um you might want to consider
but i i think that the proposal should
simply be
if members want to go down this road is
that any member ha
that has a disclosable pecuniary
interest
or other pecuniary interest in any
aspect of the the
budget should be allowed to participate
in any debate debate
and vote relating to the budget
providing they declare
the nature of their interests first and
then just stop there
i was thinking that maybe members might
want to
resolve that the specific item that has
provoked the disclosure should also
not be voted on by that particular
member but i think that becomes very
complicated
in terms of interpretation so just
leaving it as
you know if any member has a disclosable
procurement interest or pecuniary
interest they'll be allowed to
participate and vote providing they
declare that interest first of all
and that this dispensation should apply
to any member until the 21st of february
2025
for future budgets the reason i say that
chairman
is that the localism act section 33
allows this sort of dispensation
to continue for a maximum of four years
obviously if members feel that's too
long and it ought to be looked at
annually or biannually then you you can
reduce the length of the dispensation
okay thank you very much mr crouch i
shall throw that now to the committee
and uh i can see that councillor boyce
you have your hand up
um thank you chairman um this is almost
a point of
order um uh
this is a very short notice
and i don't believe that such an
important issue
as this should um be taken at this stage
um before a wider
application of advice from all
uh all of count all of council um
it's in my in my view um
i i've got no problem with the issue but
i do believe
that that that after
this meeting it would be all right
for this to come back to this committee
um for determination
um but at the at the present the notice
is too short although i accept that
you've accepted it as an urgent item
i don't think it is an urgent item
mr quash
chairman would you would you like me to
to answer that point yes
yes please mr quench if you want to uh a
chairman it is an urgent item because i
only knew about it two days ago
i only knew about the issue two days ago
um
and and it does i can't go into detail
because the information i've been given
um i i can't go into detail about that
but
the talking to the section 151 officer
chris leslie it will be far more
expeditious for business to be
transacted
and less complicated for members and
probably easier for members of the
public that are listening in
if this dispensation is granted and the
very nature of these dispensations under
section 33 with
um it is that often they do come up
at short notice sometimes they don't and
there's plenty of notice that it can be
given but
sometimes they do and if if members feel
that counsellor boyce has
a point here then you don't have to give
one for four years
you could give one just for the the
budget meeting tomorrow
so that um the committee can consider it
at more at more leisure um after
at the next meeting for for for safer
for a longer dispensation
so the trouble is if you don't deal with
it today
it will significantly complicate
the presentation of the budget and the
handling of the budget
okay i shall come back to you councillor
boyce but could i go to councillor heard
next please
yes sir thank you thank you chairman um
i'm i'm rather surprised that council of
voices
almost a point of order i mean either it
is
or it isn't uh he's saying that it's
in his view uh however it's acceptable
to the monitoring officer
and it has been delegated to this
committee to decide
uh so i'm quite comfortable with this
committee deciding
uh it's uh i think that it is
an urgent matter of business um i'm
quite
content if the committee decided that it
should be
for this once and then review it but i
think if council of voice doesn't have a
problem with the issue
i think this is just bureaucracy for the
sake of it
thank you thank you very much could i go
to councillor maze please
uh yeah thank you mr chairman i
i'm sorry councillor maze you've muted
yourself
sorry sorry mr chairman um yeah i am in
agreement with uh councillor heard
um i think that this is an important
issue i would recommend that it is only
for one
meeting um and then this matter comes
back to committee
for discussion uh at a further date
thank you
thank you uh councillor boyce would you
like to come back on those
questions thank you um chairman uh
mr quelsh is being rather
i think naive
this issue that councillor nunn
has was raised at last year's budget
so where is the urgency
thank you yes the urgency is
that um i received information two days
ago
that would significantly complicate
the expeditious transaction of business
at the budget meeting
and as a result of a meeting with a
couple of counselors
and i'm not free to tell you about this
it sounds like it's all veiled in
mystery but unfortunately
i've been asked not to disclose anything
so i cannot do so
but because disclosure was made to me
that enabled me to know certain
information i would otherwise not have
known
and so although councillor boyce says
uh we've known about this for a year
that is not the case
i can assure you chairman it is not the
case um
obviously counselor boys doesn't know
the information that i was given nor do
other members but i can assure you
but for that information i would not be
here in this committee um
raising the issue with the dispensation
being given
that's all i i can't tell you anymore
because i'm not allowed to tell you
anymore
thank you that's fair enough uh could i
go to councillor fleming please
thank you chair um i was just going to
ask mr what what happened last year we
we took the budget and
bits i seem to remember um
is that not correct that sorry chairman
chairman that that is correct yes thank
you chairman that is correct
um and i don't believe
there was a problem in doing that but
with the information i hold and i'm
sorry it does all sound very veiled
but i'm sworn to secrecy um
then um it complicates matters
significantly
for the transaction of business and what
it would do is it would disenfranchise
potentially
any members that have
a disclosable pecuniary interest as in
this case and it may not just be
councillor nern it may be on the night
chairman
um other members make disclosures that
i'm not aware of
and that disenfranchises members on a
really important matter the budget
that affects every council taxpayer and
so
democracy i would suggest chairman
requires
that with this new information i have
every member is given the maximum
opportunity
of participating in the budget not just
counsellor nun but any other member
that has such an interest could i just
go to councilman
please again
is that a legacy councilor mays you're
looking slightly startled
yes i'm terribly sorry chairman then uh
councillor voice uh your hand is still
up if you'd like to come back or is that
also a legacy
uh no chairman that's a a request to
come back and i apologize
um uh but um this issue is
so very important um of course
to me this smacks of not
openness and transparency but
the administration is frightened of not
getting their budget through
so they have connived to come up with
this
issue to make sure that they've got full
voting strength
chairman can i just can i just answer
that because i'm probably i'm better i'm
better placed than members to answer
that
i have to say councillor boys that is
not the case it is not
the conniving of the administration in
fact the administration had no
part to play in this
um this proposal of a section 33 it is
purely
information that has come to me from
another source it is not the
administration
um they had no part to play in it
whatsoever chairman
and um this is my professional advice
bearing in mind the circumstances and my
discussion with the 151 officer we are
both statutory officers and
often often we talk together about
issues and we both
agree that's chris leslie and myself
that the use of section 33 is
entirely appropriate in these
circumstances and in the interests of
democracy
okay counselor hurt
um yes thank you chairman well
i take great exception to that connived
i've certainly had no
um no dealings with it uh certainly as
part of the administration
rule 15 talks about disclosure of
interest
and it says that unless formal
dispensation has been granted and that's
exactly what we are doing here
i think council of voice is very very
well placed
to know how important uh the budget
meeting is to
all councillors irrespective of who is
in the administration
this is for the benefit of the whole
council and
and he knows very well that any
opposition parties
are at liberty to put in an alternative
budget if they wish
thank you thank you councillor mays
please
thank you mr chairman i too take
exception i was not aware
and as part of the administration uh i
would propose that
um in light of our monitoring officers
advice that we grant a dispensation
for the period of the budget meeting
this year
and then it comes back to this committee
at its earliest opportunity
to then be discussed further thank you
mr chairman
thank you councillor mays uh councillor
fleming please could i just quickly go
there
yes thank you chair um mr quelch just so
i can understand the series of
events the 151 officer came to you and
said
i'd really like to move the budget as a
one rather than
piecemeal as was practice in previous
years
then that threw up an issue which we are
now
hopefully going to try to resolve
mitigate
is that correct that's correct okay
thank you
thank you um i'm going to go to
councillor boyce again if i may
please
cameron that is legacy i'm sorry council
boys thank you i should go to councillor
herd then please
thank you chairman i'm just happy to
second uh councillor maze's um
proper uh proposal thank you thank you
councillor i was going to come back to
council amazing proposal and council
maze would you like to
is that legacy or would you like to add
something or
oh no i was actually going to ask for
for a second to my motion thank you
there we are we're all sort of going
through the wrong way so we have a
proposal on the table which is council
amazes proposal and
uh perhaps council amaze perhaps you
could repeat the proposal
so tara gets an idea of what's going on
uh yeah
um i propose that we agree with
mr quelch's recommendation for a
dispensation
for the purposes of uh the budget
meeting on the
23rd of february
2021 thank you very much and
and that this matter then come back to
uh joint standards committee for a
full debate so that's the
proposal members so could i have a
second to please which i think we
already have from councillor
thank you very much so we've all
understood that proposal
tara um is that okay with you do you
have that down
i've got that chairman i just wanted to
clarify did that relate puny to
counselor none or was that for all
councillors could i just clarify please
thank you members
um sorry mr chairman may i come back
absolutely um we we only have
the information relating to um
councillor nan can we ask mr quelch
if we are able to do it for all
councillors or whether or not it should
just be one for one councillors
so through you yes chairman yeah for all
councillors because
um the matter has now been raised um
that that's brought in section 33
and there could be other members in the
similar position to to council and none
that i do not know about
right but we are only talking about this
particular meeting aren't we and then
it's coming back
as i understand it chairman yes thank
you i can see uh councillor hull please
oh you're muted i'm afraid
sorry could we have a recorded vote
please yes of course
tara could we have a recorded vote on
this please
uh yes chairman need that second did
please
sorry yeah could we have a second day
for that
oh yeah um mr mr chairman uh council
amazon i'll second that
but could i could i before we move to
the vote
um could i just amend um as
miss byrd had pointed out um that it
should read
um that it will cover all members for
the purposes
of the forthcoming uh committee meeting
on the 23rd of
uh february 2021 and then come back to
committee fantastic excellent i think i
think that i think that amendment needs
to be
seconded as well mr chairman councilman
happy to second that
council heard thank you very much so we
we have a proposal on the table i think
we're there tara are we do we have that
confirmed
german i've got a hand up i'm sorry
council for the boyce
i beg your pardon um i i i do not wish
to be included in all councillors
i don't know how mr quelch will get over
that but a councillor must have a right
not to have an exemption
ah mr quelch can you come back on that
one please
uh well no that's not the case um
if councillor voice is not happy with
that then he doesn't have to benefit
from it
that's the point it's a dispensation if
you want
to benefit from it if you if you still
want to declare
a disclosable pecuniary interest and not
vote
nor um debate and leave the chamber then
you can
so that will be the way counselor boyce
would be able to um
to say i i don't want to be um included
in the dispensation you just simply
don't action it
okay thank you very much mr quirks i
think now i think we've sort of come
to a conclusion on this and so i'm going
to
move this proposal we have a second uh
so could we take the vote please tara
oh yes chairman of course and members if
you could just um
indicate for me uh if you're four
against when i call your name out or
abstaining please
starting with councillor bassinger
please four thank you
thank you councilman
oh thank you councillor boyce
against and can i have my vote recorded
please
yeah it is a recorded vote cancelled
boys so it will
everyone's vote will be recorded uh
councillor mrs fleming
four thank you councillor heard
four
four thank you councillor mays
four thank you cancer shauna c
four the results of that are seven
four one against and no abstentions
thank you very much
thank you very much members thank you
tara um so we shall
now move on and uh we are going to
item six which is the exclusion of the
public and press
and i move that we exclude them and that
is under section one zero zero a
four of the local government acts 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business on
the ground that they involve the likely
disclosure exempt
information as defined in paragraph one
of part one
of schedule 12a of the act and that this
satisfies the public interest so i move
that do i have a second to please
seconded councillor fleming thank you
very much and do
we can we agree that police members
agreed agreed great
thank you very much this point i would
like to thank all the members of the
public
and people who are not on this committee
to now
leave the meeting and we will move into
private session
you